Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to war, a Siberian peasant called Grigory Rasputin wrote to Nicholas II, the Tsar of all the Russians. I know they all want war from you, Rasputin wrote, evidently not realising that this means ruin. Hard is God's punishment when he takes away reason. It's the beginning of the end. You are the Tsar, father of the people. Don't allow the madmen to triumph and destroy themselves and the people. Yes, they'll conquer Germany, but what of Russia? If one thinks then truly never for all
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告内容、系列节目的抢先收听，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问……西伯利亚农民格里戈里·拉斯普京（Grigory Rasputin）致信全俄罗斯沙皇尼古拉二世：我知道他们所有人都想要你发动战争。拉斯普京写道，显然没有意识到这意味着毁灭。上帝的惩罚是严厉的，当他夺走人们的理智时。这是一切终结的开始。你是沙皇，人民之父。不要让疯子们得逞，毁灭他们自己和人民。是的，他们会征服俄罗斯，但俄罗斯将何去何从？如果人们真正去想，从古到今，有谁曾受过
of time has one suffered like russia drowned in her own blood great will be the ruin grief without end grigory and dominic um i mean that is an amazing letter is it not i mean it is kind of properly prophetic it is very prescient it survived it's one of the it's extraordinary that it survived nicholas must have kept it with him after he went into captivity, which is extraordinary. But the fact that it's being sent by a peasant to the autocrat of all the Russias, this guy who thinks he's basically,
像俄罗斯这样沉浸在自己血泊中的苦难？毁灭将是巨大的，悲伤将是没有尽头的。格里戈里和多米尼克，嗯，我的意思是这是一封令人惊叹的信，不是吗？我的意思是，它具有某种真正意义上的预言性，非常具有先见之明。它竟然留存了下来，它能留存下来真是太不可思议了。尼古拉在他被俘后一定一直把它带在身边，这真是不可思议。但这样一个事实：它是一个农民发给全俄罗斯的专制君主，这个自认为基本上是……
who's the last sort of absolute monarch in Europe, ordained by God, and he's getting advice from this sort of bedraggled, yeah, from this peasant, this relatively uneducated. And this peasant is at the heart of great events. So the descent of Europe into war, Russia's role in it, in the long run, the Russian revolution. So today's episode is focused on Rasputin, a figure of enormous kind of historical fascination. And we've had a lot of questions, a lot of questions about him.
这个欧洲最后一种专制君王、受上帝之命的人，却在听取这种落魄的、是的，这个农民、这个相对受教育程度不高的农民的建议。而这个农民却处于重大事件的核心。因此，欧洲陷入战争，俄罗斯在其中的角色，从长远来看，还有俄国革命。所以今天的节目重点是拉斯普京，一个在历史上有巨大吸引力的人物。我们收到了很多问题，关于他的很多问题。
And I would say the overwhelming tenor of those questions. Well, I'll read one from Benjamin Bitton, who I'll quote. Is it true that when his drinking and lusting and his hunger for power became known to more and more people, the demands to do something about this outrageous man became louder and louder. The words there, of course, not only from Benjamin Bitton, but from Boney M., whose Rasputin has been name-checked so many times. Most people will know him through Boney M., won't they? More than through history books or anything like that.
我想说的是，这些问题压倒性的基调……好吧，我来读一位听众本杰明·比特恩（Benjamin Bitton）的问题，我引述一下：当他的酗酒、好色和对权力的渴望被越来越多的人所知晓时，要求对这个离谱的男人采取行动的呼声是否越来越高？当然，这里的言论不仅来自本杰明·比特恩，还来自波尼M合唱团（Boney M.），他们的歌曲《拉斯普京》被多次提及。大多数人都是通过波尼M合唱团认识他的，对吧？比起历史书籍或类似的东西，更多是通过这种方式。
So was he the lover of the Russian queen? Before we get onto that, Tom, I have an exciting announcement for our listeners. Do you? Well, we've been going for more than a year, just over a year, I think. And we've been thrilled, haven't we, by the reaction from people listening to the podcast. So thrilled, in fact, that we've decided to set up our own community, our own club, the Rest Is History Club. Do you want to tell people about that?
那么，他是俄罗斯女王的情夫吗？在讨论这个之前，汤姆，我有一个激动人心的消息要宣布给我们的听众。是吗？嗯，我们已经开办了一年多了，刚过一年，我想。我们对听众们的反应感到非常兴奋，不是吗？兴奋到我们决定建立我们自己的社区，我们自己的俱乐部——“历史的余烬俱乐部”（The Rest Is History Club）。你想跟听众们讲讲这个吗？
You can listen to every episode, including the archive, without ads. I know, because the ads don't, some people don't care for some of your ads, I think it's fair to say. I think you've worn in particular. I don't want to put off that mental health charity from investing again in that show.
你可以收听每一集节目，包括资料库里的内容，都是没有广告的。我知道，因为这些广告……有些人可能不太喜欢你的某些广告，我觉得这样说挺公平的。尤其是你参与的那一个。我可不想吓得那个心理健康慈善机构以后不敢再投资这个节目了。
You're going on about Tiny Tom. I mean, that joke was funny the first hundred times. But if you want to get rid of that, you can sign up to this and you'll get every episode ad free. You will also get an extra episode every week. The content of which will be led by you, the listeners. So we will, you know, if you've got views on the episodes that you've heard, if you want to carry on the conversation, let us know and we will kind of go over that.
你一直在说“小汤姆”（Tiny Tom）。我的意思是，这个笑话头一百次听起来还挺好笑的。但如果你想摆脱广告，你可以注册加入这个俱乐部，这样你就能获得每一集无广告的节目。你还会在每周获得一集额外的节目。其中的内容将由你们——听众来主导。所以，如果你对听过的节目有看法，如果你想延续对话，让我们知道，我们就会去讨论那些内容。
That's right. And if you sign up now, you will find the first of these episodes is up right now and there'll be a preview out tomorrow. On the main feed. So even if you don't sign up, you'll get a preview of that bonus episode. And Dominic, what is that episode on?
没。错。而且如果你现在注册，你会发现这些节目中的第一期现在就已经上线了，明天还会在主信息流里发布一个预览。所以，即使你不注册，你也能听到那个加更节目的预览。多米尼克，那一集节目是关于什么的？
Aptly, it's on history's greatest clubs. So the Kit Kat Club, the Hellfire Club, a gentleman's club that I believe a member of the Rest is History team is a member of. And now the Rest is History Club. And the Rest is History Club. So that's great. And also we will be doing a live streamed episode once every month. For club members. Yeah. And the first one will be next week. So Wednesday, the 15th of December.
很应景，讲的是历史上最伟大的俱乐部。比如基特卡特俱乐部（Kit Kat Club）、地狱火俱乐部（Hellfire Club）——一个绅士俱乐部，据信“历史的余烬”团队里的一名成员就是其中的一员，现在还有“历史的余烬俱乐部”。还有“历史的余烬俱乐部”。所以这太棒了。此外，我们还将每月进行一次直播节目。为俱乐部成员举办的。是的。第一场将在下周举行。也就是12月15日，星期三。
And we'll be doing that on the 60s, the 1960s. So you can watch and you can contribute to the episode. You can send an abuse while we're recording it. Yeah. Kind of laugh at Dominic while you're doing it. And also there is apparently there is a chat room community called discord which just seems absolutely absolutely perfect um so you can join that and we will be discussing episodes taking suggestions um and giving reading lists won't we yeah it says here sharing historical memes we're not going to be doing that no we're
我们将在节目中讨论60年代，即20世纪60年代。所以你可以观看并且参与到节目中来。你可以在我们录制的时候对我们进行各种辱骂。是的。一边做一边嘲笑多米尼克。而且显然还有一个名为Discord的聊天室社区，这看起来绝对、绝对完美，嗯，所以你可以加入我们，我们将讨论节目、接受建议，还会提供书单，对吧？
not going to because i'm not i'm over 50 it's far too yeah if you start posting gifs or whatever i should be very disappointed in you i occasionally post a gif but i'm not a meme um right so uh so that's part of it as well uh and there are other benefits as well and how do you get how do you sign up to this incredible offer uh when you go to restishistorypod.com, restishistorypod.com, or you can click on the link in the show notes. So it's really simple, actually. It's very simple. It lives in whatever podcast app you normally use, it says here.
对，这里写着“分享历史表情包”。我们可不会做那种事，不，我们不会去做的，因为我不是……我过50岁了，这太……对，如果你开始发动图或者别的什么，我对你可就太失望了。我偶尔会发个动图，但我不是一个表情包……好。所以，这也是其中的一部分，还有其他福利。那么，你该如何注册这个令人难以置信的优惠呢？你可以访问 restishistorypod.com，restishistorypod.com，或者点击节目文稿中的链接。所以，其实非常简单。非常简单。它就存在于你通常使用的任何播客应用中，这里是这么说的。
I love hearing you say that. And it takes you 30 seconds to sign up. Not even 30 seconds, actually, because I've done it. And it took about five seconds. So I'm afraid you do actually have to pay for this but it's absolute bargain isn't it dominic it's a bargain a bargain six pounds a month so that's maybe less than two pounds a week um now the important thing to say is that if you don't care for you're not you're unclubbable uh and you don't want to join and
我喜欢听你这么说。注册只需30秒。其实甚至不用30秒，因为我已经注册过了。大约只用了五秒钟。所以，恐怕你们确实需要为之付费，但绝对是一笔划算的买卖，对吧，多米尼克？这是一笔买卖，一笔划算的买卖，一个月六英镑，可能还不到每周两英镑。嗯，现在要说的一件重要事情是，如果你不在乎，你是不喜欢加入俱乐部的那种人，你不想加入，并
you want to carry on listening for free then you just carry on listening as normal nothing has changed you're just missing out on the live stream the bonus episode the chance to see tom holland's memes all that but um although the positive is that you'll hear my adverts for mental health that's sweet and roundabout yeah it is ups and downs it's win-win you win some yeah yeah you do right okay so that's enough um that's enough uh self-promotion yes so that that that basically the bony m lover of the russian queen yeah that's his reputation it's all it's all well we'll unpack all this we'll unpack all this so should we start by talking about who rasputin is um so he's born in 1869 he's Grigory Yefimovich Rasputin, and he comes from a place called Pokrovskoe,
且你想继续免费收听，那么你就照常继续收听，一切都没有改变。你只是错过了直播、加更节目、看到汤姆·霍兰德表情包的机会以及所有这些，但是……不过积极的一面是，你会听到我关于心理健康的广告。这倒是个甜蜜的循环。是的，有起有落，这是双赢，你总能……是的，没错。好吧，那么这些就够了……自我宣传就到这里。是的，所以基本上那个波尼M歌里的“俄罗斯女王的情夫”——是的，那是他的名声，这一切都……好吧，我们会剖析这一切，我们会剖析这一切。那么，我们应该先谈谈拉斯普京是谁吗？嗯，所以他出生于1869年，他叫格里戈里·叶菲莫维奇·拉斯普京（Grigory Yefimovich Rasputin），他来自一个叫
just over the Urals in Siberia, an absolute kind of flea-bitten, kind of down-at-heel kind of village in the middle of nowhere. But free, isn't it? So Siberia is free. Once you go across the Urals, you're no longer a serf. Exactly. So people have gone there.
波克罗夫斯科耶（Pokrovskoe）的地方，就在西伯利亚乌拉尔山脉的那一边，一个绝对破破烂烂的、穷困潦倒的、位于穷乡僻壤的村庄。但是它是自由的，对吧？所以西伯利亚是自由的。一旦你跨过乌拉尔山脉，你就不再是农奴了。确切地说。所以人们去了那里。
His family, I think, go in the 17th century, is it? Yes, 1643 they settled. Good knowledge. So the year after the outbreak of the Civil War. That's how I remembered it. So they've been there all this time and they've done nothing. They've left no mark in history. They have this odd name.
他的家族，我想是在17世纪去的，对吧？是的，他们在1643年定居。了解得真多。所以是在内战爆发的后一年。我是这么记住的。所以他们一直呆在那里，什么也没做。他们在历史上没有留下任何痕迹。他们有一个奇怪的名字。
So what English sort of speakers won't get is that rasputin then the surname it's a bit like being called mr rascal or something isn't it because our rasputnik is a sort of ne'er-do-well or there's something to do with the crossroads that i don't fully understand but basically the um the the name is is sort of a loaded name you know it's clearly a kind of a name from the lower orders and a sort of scruffy ne'er-do-wells kind of name but isn't that i mean i've often read this about the about the settlement of siberia that it's kind of like russia's world west i suppose it's yes i think exactly that's exactly and so the the kind of the hint of the frontiersman absolutely and it's also it's not but it's got something a bit more
所以英国英语使用者可能不太明白的是，拉斯普京这个姓氏，有点像被称为“流氓先生”之类的不？因为“rasputnik”是一种游手好闲的人，或者跟十字路口有关，我并不是完全理解，但基本上，这个名字是一个带有某种含义的名字，你知道，这显然是一个来自社会下层、有点邋遢的游手好闲之徒的名字。但是，难道不是吗？我经常读到关于西伯利亚定居点的这种说法，它有点像俄罗斯的西部蛮荒，我想是的，我完全这样认为。所以，这种带有边疆客暗示的色彩绝对是存在的，而且它不仅仅是……
than the american frontier i think because there is this hint of well something that dogs disputing throughout his life is this stuff about religious sectarianism and heresy so there's this sense if you're in st petersburg particularly or moscow i suppose that out there and the siberian frontier are all kinds of weird sects and they're worshipping devils and all this sort of stuff but also the converse of that that somehow you are close to god out there yeah so if rasputin's name has the kind of the slight hint of of the sinister about it his first name gregory he's named after gregory of nysa who is one of the great saints of fourth century Byzantium. He's actually, I mean, interesting in the context of serfdom, he's the church father who first argues that slavery as an institution is unacceptable to God. And so you do, it's this
但它比美国边疆区似乎更有一点……因为有一种暗示，或者说纠缠拉斯普京一生的东西，就是关于宗教宗派主义和异端的这些传闻。所以如果你身处圣彼得堡，特别是莫斯科，你就会觉得在西伯利亚边疆有各种各样的奇怪教派，他们在崇拜魔鬼以及诸如此类的东西。但与此相反的是，在那种地方你某种程度上又离上帝很近。是的，所以如果拉斯普京的名字带有一丝不祥的暗示的话，他的名字格里戈里（Gregory）是根据尼斯的格里戈里（Gregory of Nysa）命名的，他是公元4世纪拜占庭伟大的圣人之一。实际上，我的意思是，在农奴制的背景下很有趣，他是第一个提出奴隶制作为一种制度是上帝所不能接受的教会之父。所以你会发现，这是一种
kind of strange mix of the kind of the rascally, the kind of frontiersman with the very holy. And the question of whether Rasputin is a genuine holy man or whether he's a kind of sinister fraud, of course, is the great question that comes to royal Russia and continues to kind of complex historians to this day. But the funny thing about him is that we know so little, isn't it? So that there are lots of things written about his early life. So, for example, there's a claim about him as a young man that he was a horse thief and that the other villagers were cross with him being a horse thief and they threw him down on the ground. Did you see this?
一种奇怪的混合，既有无赖、边疆客的色彩，又非常神圣。而关于拉斯普京究竟是一个真正的圣人，还是某种险恶的骗子的这个问题，当然是摆在皇室俄罗斯面前的巨大问题，并继续令至今的许多历史学家感到困惑。但关于他最有趣的事情是，我们对他的了解是如此之少，不是吗？所以有很多关于他早年生活的说法。例如，有人声称他年轻时是个小偷，其他村民对他是小偷很不满，把他摔倒在地上。你看到这个了吗？
They threw him down on the ground so violently that he fell on his genitals and from that point on would suffer from terrible pre-epism. So he had a permanent erection. This is totally untrue. Completely untrue. Appears to be utterly untrue. In fact, we know nothing at all about... Sorry, go on. What about his penis?
他们把他重重地摔在地上，以至于他摔在了生殖器上，从那以后他就患上了可怕的持续勃起症（priapism）。所以他一直处于勃起状态。这完全是假的。完全是假的。似乎完全是假的。事实上，我们对……对不起，请继续。他的阴茎怎么了？
No, we'll come to that later because that will play quite significant. But we do know about his penis, don't we? Yeah, we know that there's nothing very interesting about it. Well, apparently it was quite dark. It was quite dark brown. Yes, I heard. But it wasn't particularly long quite dark it was quite dark brown yes i heard but it wasn't particularly long is it dark brown or i thought the guy was saying the rest of him was dark brown but his member wasn't anyway maybe well anyway it's it's it's the pigmentation is neither here nor there
不，我们待会儿再谈这个，因为这会起到相当重要的作用。但我们确实知道他的阴茎是怎么样的，对吧？是的，我们知道它没有什么非常有趣的地方。嗯，显然它是相当黑的。它是深褐色的。是的，我听说过。但它其实并不是特别长……它是深褐色的，还是我听那家伙说他的其余部分是深褐色的，但他的那个器官不是？总之，也许……好吧，不管怎样，它的色素沉着并不重要，
but it's not particularly long and it's not permanently erect no so he he's there in this village he's a peasant he marries a peasant woman called pras govia and they have they have three children so he's got an absolutely standard life and then he clearly has in 1897 or so when he's just late 20s coming up to 30 he has some sort of breakdown doesn't he well it i mean for on this i guess on the kind of the measure of the russian peasantry it's a midlife crisis. Yeah, it is. It absolutely is.
但它并不是特别长，也没有永久勃起。不，所以他呆在那个村子里，他是一个农民，他娶了一个叫普拉斯科维娅（Praskovia）的农妇，他们有三个孩子。所以他过着绝对标准的生活。然后大约在1897年左右，他二十多岁快三十岁的时候，他显然经历了一次某种精神崩溃，不是吗？嗯，我的意思是，对此，我想以俄罗斯农民的标准来看，这是一场中年危机。是的，确实如此。绝对是这样。
He just thinks, God, this is awful. I'm going to go on a pilgrimage. So he wants to become, there are these people called the Straniki. So he wants to be a Stranik, which means he's going to go off and he's going to commune with nature and with God. And he will wander about the countryside. Wearing chains, right? Yes. He wears fetters at first.
他只是觉得，天哪，这太糟糕了。我要去朝圣。所以他想成为……有这样一群人被称为“苦行流浪者”（Straniki）。所以他想成为一个Stranik，这意味着他要离开这里，去与大自然和上帝交流。他会在乡间四处游荡。戴着铁链，对吗？是的。他一开始戴着镣铐。
So this is very kind of, you know, it's very kind of Byzantine behaviour, isn't it? You can imagine somebody doing this in Syria. Kind of holy fool. Exactly, exactly. This is what he does. And he pitches up at a place called Verkatoria in the Urals, which is a monastery.
所以这非常……你知道，这非常具有拜占庭式的行为，不是吗？你可以想象有人在叙利亚这样做。某种神圣的傻子。确切地说，确切地说。这就是他所做的。他来到了乌拉尔山脉一个叫韦尔霍图里耶（Verkhoturye）的地方，那里有一座修道院。
And this is a place where there's lots of elders and stuff. And anybody who's dostoevsky will know the import the importance the sort of holy men and elders and monks and people of this kind i mean they're all different kind of versions karamazov and all that i mean i have to say that um the reading about rasputin who i didn't know a huge amount about i mean just really bonnie m was basically the limit of my knowledge but i do love um dostoevsky and throughout reading about him the echoes of dostoevsky's novels absolutely keep kind of coming um and i guess that you know a lot of the themes that dostoevsky is tackling are obviously part of of of this kind of the the tensions and the social conflicts, religious
这是一个有很多长老之类的地方。任何读过陀思妥耶夫斯基的人都会知道那些圣人、长老、僧侣和这类人的重要性……我的意思是，他们有各种各样版本的卡拉马佐夫等等。我的意思是，我必须说，在阅读关于拉斯普京的资料时——我对他的了解并不多，基本上波尼M就是我的知识极限——我真的很喜欢陀思妥耶夫斯基，在阅读关于他的过程中，陀思妥耶夫斯基小说的回响一直在不断涌现……我想你知道，陀思妥耶夫斯基正在处理的许多主题显然是……
conflicts, the stresses in Russian life, that part of the reason, obviously, I guess, why Rasputin has this cut through is that he just embodies all these tensions. He does, doesn't he? So it's about sort of the clash between the urban modernity of St. Petersburg
俄罗斯生活中的这种紧张局势、社会冲突、宗教冲突和压力的组成部分。部分原因，显然，我想，为什么拉斯普京有这么大的影响力，是因为他体现了所有这些紧张关系。他确实如此，不是吗？所以这关乎圣彼得堡的城市现代性
and this kind of vanishing world of kind of a mystical, rural, peasant Russia. That's all there in Rasputin's story, isn't it? And it's all there in, you know, it's there in Dostoevsky's work in the picture of St. Petersburg in Crime and Punishment. Once you've read that, it's quite hard to rid yourself of that when you're reading about Rasputin when he finally goes to the imperial capital. So anyway, he decides he what he's
与这种神秘的、乡村的、农民的俄罗斯的消逝世界之间的冲突。拉斯普京的故事里都有这一切，对吧？陀思妥耶夫斯基的作品中也有这一切，比如《罪与罚》中对圣彼得堡的描绘。一旦你读过那本书，当你读到拉斯普京最终前往帝国首都时，你就很难摆脱那种印象了。所以无论如何，他决定他……他曾去那里朝圣，没有理由怀疑这是真诚的，因为对他来说有什么好处呢？他离开了他的村庄，去朝圣，然后回来，决定他想成为某种圣人。好吧，所以我想……我想这里有一个来自“深思熟虑的天主教徒”（thoughtfully catholic）的问题：拉斯普京是否提出过任何神学上非正统的观点，或者他只是正统信仰体系内部众多有个人魅力的奇特人物之一？所以本质上他是一个异端吗？
had this pilgrimage there's no reason to doubt that this is sincere I mean because what's in it for him he's he's left his village he's gone on the pilgrimage he comes back he decides he wants to be kind of a holy man well okay so I think I mean I think there's some there's a question here from uh thoughtfully catholic yeah did rasputin propose anything theologically unorthodox or was he simply one of the many charismatic figures within the national the normal framework of orthodoxy so essentially was he you know was he a heretic no i don't think he was or was he a conventional you know was he conventionally religious well i mean you and i both read this
还是他是一个传统的……他是一个传统意义上的信教者吗？好吧，我的意思是，你和我读了这本由道格拉斯·史密斯（Douglas Smith）写的书，这是一本令人惊叹的传记，关于拉斯普京及其生平极其详细的传记。这本书贯穿着这样一种猜疑：人们，特别是他在正统宗教世界里的竞争对手，以及圣彼得堡的贵族和官员等，认为他是一个教派异端。
book by douglas smith this amazing biography incredibly detailed biography of rasputin and rasputin's life and times and running through this book is the is the suspicion that people had particularly in sort of his rivals within the orthodox kind of world but also kind of aristocrats and officials and stuff in st petersburg that he was a sectarian. And they were particularly anxious and worried that he was what's called a clist. So these are kind of flagellants. And these are seen as absolutely beyond the pale. There's about 100,000 of them in Russia at the end of the 19th century. And there's all this talk, he must be a heretic.
他们特别焦虑和担心他被称为“鞭身派”（Khlysty）。这些人是一群苦行鞭笞者。在当时的社会看来，这些人简直是不可接受的。19世纪末，俄罗斯大约有10万名这样的人。因此流言四起，认为他一定是个异端。
He must be, you know, a sectarian. He's whipping himself. But this seems to be completely untrue. That actually, theologically, he's whipping himself but this seems to be completely untrue that actually theologically he's pretty standard that the the clisty are um supposed to to dance and then to end up having kind of vast orgies yes and there's that subsection of them that you talked about in our program on eunuchs the scopsy that they hack off their testicles or their breasts or whatever um and again you get this kind of this obsessional interest where kind of extreme radical desire for god asceticism kind of blurs and blends into kind of basically a genital obsession yes that's you yeah well that's
他一定是个宗派分子，你知道的，他在鞭笞自己。但这似乎完全不属实。事实上，在神学上，他鞭笞自己，但似乎完全不属实，事实上在神学上他相当标准，即苦行派嗯应该跳舞，然后最终举行某种宏大的狂欢。是的，其中有一个细分群体，你在我们关于阉人的节目中谈到过，即苦行阉人派，他们砍掉自己的睾丸或乳房或其他什么东西嗯，再次你会发现这种迷恋，极端激进的对上帝的渴望、苦行，在某种程度上变得模糊并融合成了一种基本上对生殖器的迷恋，是的，就是这样，嗯，这就是
why this is why i find this subject so interesting. Yeah. But anyway, I don't think this is right with Rasputin. I think Rasputin, because in Douglas Smith's, I mean, it's an amazing biography. And in his biography, he has lots of stuff from Rasputin's letters and what people heard him say and so on. And it's all kind of quite, it's all a little bit primary school head teacher. You know, God is love. Be in touch with the natural world be kind yeah yeah you know it's absolutely nothing outlandish or or that anyone it's actually quite bland do you not think kind of thought for the day it is very thought for the day respite would be an absolute
为什么我觉得这个主题如此有趣。是的。但无论如何，我不认为这适用于拉斯普京。我认为拉斯普京，因为在道格拉斯·史密斯的书中，我的意思是，这是一本令人惊叹的传记。在他的传记中，他有很多来自拉斯普京信件的材料，以及人们听到他说的话等等。这一切都有点，这一切都有点像小学校长。你知道的，上帝就是爱。与自然世界保持联系，要善良，是的，是的，你知道的，绝对没有什么离奇的，或者任何人，实际上相当平淡，你不觉得有点像每日沉思吗，非常适合每日沉思，拉斯普京会是一个绝对的
regular anyway good that that path was not open to him he officially gets investigated doesn't he he does was multiple investigations. And he gets a kind of clean bit of help. And I thought that one of the really interesting comments on him was made in 1918, so after he died and after the Russian Revolution, when no one had any interest in sticking up for him. And somebody passes through his village and they ask about him. And the overwhelming consensus is that he was a kind-hearted person
常客无论如何，庆幸的是那条路对他来说没有走通，他受到了官方调查，不是吗？他确实受到了多次调查。他得到了某种清白的证明。我认为关于他的一个非常有趣的评论是在1918年做出的，也就是在他死后和俄国革命之后，当时没有人有兴趣为他撑腰。有人途经他的村庄，打听他的消息。压倒性的共识是，他是一个心地善良的人
and that he was a kind-hearted person and that he was a man of god uh and that i i mean that seems to i think the evidence that he was essentially an orthodox figure seems pretty clear yeah i think i think that's that's that's pretty right but anyway no one would care about him if he hadn't made this journey so he goes to kazan which is this kind of tatar city and he's a bit of a... So this is... We should paint the context, shouldn't we? Because Russia is in a very bad place when he's on his sort of travels
而且他是一个心地善良的人，他是一个上帝的人，嗯，我的意思是，这似乎，我认为他是本质上正统人物的证据似乎相当清楚。是的，我想，我想这，这，这挺对的。但无论如何，如果他没有进行这次旅行，没有人会关心他，所以他去了喀山，这是一个有点像鞑靼人的城市，他有点……所以这是……我们应该描绘一下背景，对吧？因为当他在进行某种旅行时，俄罗斯正处于一个非常糟糕的境地
in the late 1890s and early 1900s. It's very repressive, very divided, in some ways incredibly backward. So, you know, serfdom is within living memory. A lot of people in the countryside living in intense poverty but at the same time it is industrializing and urbanizing at a at a kind of breakneck a kind of chinese rate which causes all kinds of problems of its own the political system hasn't caught up at all kind of buckling and straining under absolutely yeah and all the
在19世纪90年代末和20世纪初。这里非常压抑、非常分裂，在某些方面极其落后。所以，你知道的，农奴制还在人们的记忆中。乡下的许多人生活在极度的贫困中，但与此同时，它正以一种惊人的速度进行工业化和城市化，一种中国速度，这本身就引起了各种各样的问题，政治系统根本没有跟上，在绝对的压力下摇摇欲坠，是的，而且所有的
elite are they like a lot of their counterparts elsewhere in europe they have become obsessed but in this incredibly sort of neurotic morbid way with the occult with seances with hypnotism everybody believes in what they call dark forces so it's just a absolute standard belief among the sort of russian elite that there are there are conspiracies often with the jews yeah Jews or the Freemasons playing key roles that are responsible for all the ills of Russia. And because of that fascination, it means that when Rasputin, he merely has to arrive in a place, it seems, and kind of aristocrats and bigwigs will take him up and be interested in him and sort of show him off as a bit of a
精英们，他们就像他们在欧洲其他地方的许多同行一样，已经变得痴迷，但以这种极其神经质、病态的方式沉迷于神秘学、降神会、催眠术，每个人都相信他们所说的黑暗力量，所以这简直是俄罗斯精英阶层中的绝对标准信仰，即存在着阴谋，通常有犹太人，是的，犹太人或共济会员在其中扮演关键角色，他们应对俄罗斯的所有弊病负责。正因为这种痴迷，这意味着当拉斯普京仅仅到达一个地方时，似乎贵族和大人物就会接纳他，对他感兴趣，并把他当作某种
grotesque yeah in their salons and stuff but i think also i mean one of the things that that um i picked up from my admittedly cursory reading of the kind of the climate into which rasputin enters is that actually the hint of the the kind of the sinister the the demonic, intermixed with the saintly, is actually incredibly appealing to people. Yes. That that's kind of a selling point. So there's this terrifyingly, kind of clearly charismatic
怪胎来炫耀，是的，在他们的沙龙之类的场所。但我认为，从我对我所进入的拉斯普京所处的环境所作的、不可否认是粗略的阅读中，我所领会到的事情之一是，实际上，带有某种阴险、恶魔般色彩的东西与圣洁交织在一起，对人们来说实际上具有难以置信的吸引力。是的。这算是一个卖点。所以这里有一个极其恐怖的、显然具有超凡魅力的
and basically diabolic figure, Alexei, is it Shdetetinin? I hope my pronunciation there is right. Beautifully, beautiful Russian. Yeah, who is a clist, I think. Yeah. And he arrives in St. Petersburg in in 1906 which is basically around the same time as as rasputin is turning up and he is i mean he is basically a kind of a drunk a rogue um he encourages his followers to give them give him all their money to give their wives. Yes. And it's an awful, awful thing that he wants his followers to do,
基本上属于魔鬼似的人物，阿列克谢，是什杰捷宁吗？我希望我那里的发音是正确的。非常漂亮，非常美的俄语。是的，他大概是一个苦行派成员。是的。他于1906年来到圣彼得堡，基本上也就是在拉斯普京出现的同时，他，我的意思是，他基本上是一个酒鬼、流氓，嗯，他鼓励他的追随者把所有的钱都给他，给他们的妻子。是的。这是一件可怕的、可怕的事情，他希望他的追随者去做，
which is to give their children over to him, and he will then put them in orphanages. That's right. So that they will never be able to find them, even if they then repent it. It's just awful. And then he gets put in prison for for raping a uh underage girl uh rather like um stavrogin does in dostoevsky's um uh the devils yeah i mean it's all kind of incredibly reminiscent of that uh and and
那就是把他们的孩子交给他，然后他会把他们送进孤儿院。没错。这样他们就永远找不到他们了，即使他们后来对此感到后悔。这简直太可怕了。然后他因为强奸一个未成年女孩而被投入监狱，这有点像陀思妥耶夫斯基的《群魔》中斯塔夫罗金所做的那样，是的，我的意思是，这一切都让人难以置信地想起那个，并且
women who go to see him in prison because he you know they kind of remain obsessed by him they write about him as being both god and satan at the same time and this is all the kind of stuff that will then be said about Rasputin. But I think that Rasputin is not of that order really at all. His behavior is a bit dubious. We'll come to his behavior, I think. I think you're right that Rasputin is not. There's no reason at this point to believe that he's a fraud or a charlatan
去看望他的女性在监狱里，因为他，你知道的，她们仍然对她着迷，她们写关于他的文章，说他既是上帝又是撒旦，这也就是后来会被用来形容拉斯普京的所有言论。但我认为拉斯普京根本不是那种性质的人。他的行为有点可疑。我想我们稍后会谈到他的行为。我认为你说得对，拉斯普京不是那样的人。目前没有理由相信他是一个骗子或江湖郎中
or motivated purely by self-interest or by greed or anything like that. He's just found his calling and and his and his his path leads him to st petersburg now when he gets to st petersburg he's taken up by or he comes to the attention of these two montenegrin sisters aren't they called the black the black women or the black crows they have very let's call them the black crows yeah that's never a very appealing never a very appealing label i think so the black crows they have very let's call them the black crows yeah that's never a very appealing never a very appealing label i think so the black crows are connected with the the royal family they've married into the imperial family i think haven't they and they and through them i
或者完全出于自私、贪婪或类似动机。他只是找到了自己的召唤，他的道路引导他来到了圣彼得堡。现在当他来到圣彼得堡时，他被这两位黑山姐妹接纳，或者进入了她们的视线，她们不是被称为黑人姐妹或黑乌鸦吗？她们有非常，让我们管她们叫黑乌鸦吧，是的，这绝不是一个很有吸引力的标签，绝不是一个很有吸引力的标签，我想是这样的，所以黑乌鸦与皇室有联系，她们嫁入了皇室家族，我想是的，通过她们，我
think he gets to meet nicholas and alexandra isn't that also there is um there's's a very high-ranking official kind of bishop, archbishop in the Orthodox Church, Theophan. Oh, yes. Who's a big fan. Theophan, yeah. There's also another bishop, isn't there, called Germagen, who castrated himself. So, you know, this is basically the milieu in which Rasputin is moving,
认为他得以见到尼古拉和亚历山大，难道不是吗？还有一个，嗯，有一个东正教会的高级官员，主教，大主教狄奥法恩。哦，是的。他是狂热粉丝。狄奥法恩，是的。还有另一个主教，对吧，叫杰尔马根，他阉割了自己。所以，你知道的，这基本上就是拉斯普京所处的环境，
a very sort of strange and feverish kind of world. So Nicholas and Alexandra, I mean, we should talk about them a bit, shouldn't we? So Nicholas, born in 1868, Alex, as she's called. So she's Queen Victoria's granddaughter, I think, isn't she? And she's terribly serious and earnest, and she's German. German, yeah. And everybody hates her, basically,
一个非常奇怪且狂热的世界。所以尼古拉和亚历山大，我的意思是，我们应该稍微谈谈他们，对吧？所以尼古拉生于1868年，亚历克斯，人们这么叫她。所以她是维多利亚女王的孙女，我想是的，对吧？她非常严肃认真，而且她是德国人。德国人，是的。基本上所有人都讨厌她，
because she has that thing that people sometimes have. She's very shy and anxious. And so everyone thinks she's being haughty. And she just never, ever adapts and clearly never really understands Russia. And they don't understand her. And basically, she and Nicholas become increasingly isolated. All the other people in the elite despise them. Yeah.
因为她有那种人们有时会有的特质。她非常害羞和焦虑。所以每个人都认为她傲慢。而且她从来、从来没有适应过，显然也从未真正理解俄罗斯。而他们也不理解她。基本上，她和尼古拉变得越来越孤立。精英阶层中的所有人都在鄙视他们。是的。
And they're politically utterly useless and inept and and also um alexandra carries haemophilia she does well she has already so she's had four daughters um olga tatiana maria and anastasia and she's desperate for a boy very sort of henry the eighth style it's a thing going on at the court she's desperate for a boy. Very sort of Henry VIII style thing going on at the court. She's desperate for a boy. And so she's already had one kind of crank, hasn't she? This guy called Monsieur Philippe, who's a... He's a cultist. He's a butcher's apprentice from Lyon.
而且他们在政治上完全无用且无能，并且，嗯，亚历山大携带血友病基因，她确实如此，好吧，她已经有了，所以她已经有了四个女儿——奥尔加、塔蒂亚娜、玛丽亚和阿Anastasia（阿娜斯塔西娅），她极度渴望一个男孩，非常具有亨利八世的风格，宫廷里正在发生这种事。她极度渴望一个男孩。非常具有亨利八世风格的事情正在宫廷里发生。她极度渴望一个男孩。所以她已经经历过一个怪人了，不是吗？这家伙叫菲利普先生，他是一个……他是个邪教徒。他是里昂的一个屠夫学徒。
He's a hypnotist and stuff, isn't he? And he pitches up at the court and they hang around with him. Eventually, everyone persuades them to kick him out. But it just shows that Alex... is very susceptible they're both incredibly susceptible um but even specifically isn't it the the haemophilia of their son when he gets born well yeah so they've had four daughters yes and then alexa is born in 1904 so he's the heir and he's he exactly they realize pretty much straight away that he's hemophiliac and the base of the life expectancy is about 13 so if you're if you're if you're
他是一个催眠师之类的，对吧？他来到宫廷，他们和他厮混在一起。最终，每个人都说服他们把他踢出去。但这只是表明亚历克斯……非常容易轻信，他们俩都极其容易轻信，嗯，但具体来说，不是吗？当他们的儿子出生时患有血友病，哦，是的，所以他们已经有了四个女儿，是的，然后阿列克谢在1904年出生，所以他是继承人，他确实，他们几乎立刻就意识到他是血友病患者，并且平均预期寿命大约是13岁，所以如果你，如果你，如果你
neurotic if you're isolated if you're desperate for a male heir this is a terrible emotional position to be in i mean she's so vulnerable to yeah yeah and what's then worse is that exactly as Rasputin arrives in St. Petersburg, this sort of European-style foggy city on the banks of the Neva in the far northwestern corner of this kind of closed world where everybody is plotting and there's just this sort of miasma of sort of, I don't know, morbid kind of introspection and stuff. There's been the revolution in 1905. So they've lost a war to the Japanese. Troops have fired on the crowds. There's been rioting and all sorts of disturbances across the country. And Nicholas has been forced to grant effectively a constitution, a constitutional monarchy, which is the one thing he never wanted to do because his father had told him told him you know that way lies degeneracy and you must rule as an autocrat and you must never give up any of
神经质，如果你被孤立，如果你极度渴望一个男性继承人，这是一种可怕的情感处境，我的意思是她太脆弱了，以至于，是的，更糟糕的是，就在拉斯普京到达圣彼得堡的时候，这个欧洲风格的雾城，位于涅瓦河岸边，在这个封闭世界的远西北角，每个人都在密谋，这里只有一种……我不知道，病态的内省等等的瘴气。1905年发生了革命。所以他们在一场对日本的战争中失败了。军队向人群开枪。全国各地都发生了暴动和各种骚乱。尼古拉被迫实际上颁布了一部宪法，实行君主立宪制，这是他最不想做的事，因为他的父亲曾告诉过他，你知道的，那条路通向堕落，你必须以专制君主的身份统治，你绝不能放弃任何
your authority so just when they're at their lowest ebb they meet rasputin and i think a lot of it is that they see him as the as the sort of soul of russia at a time when no they have no friends and they feel they have no political allies and all their family hate them. Kind of old Russia, the heart of old Russia. Because he, yes, yeah. Because he's quite conservative, isn't he, politically, Rasputin? Incredibly. You know, he sort of says...
你的权力，所以正当他们处于最低谷时，他们遇到了拉斯普京，我认为很大程度上是因为他们把他视为俄罗斯的灵魂，在一个他们没有朋友、觉得没有政治盟友且所有家人都讨厌他们的时代。某种旧俄罗斯，旧俄罗斯的心脏。因为他，是的，是的。因为他在政治上相当保守，不是吗，拉斯普京？极其保守。你知道，他基本上说……
He has an absolutely medieval sense of the Tsar. Exactly. As the God-appointed father of... So he basically says exactly... Because Alexandra knows that Nicholas has the spine of an amoeba. Yeah. And so he basically she's very keen for him to hang around with rasputin because she thinks rasputin will sort of
他对沙皇有一种绝对中世纪式的理解。没错。将其视为上帝指定的……所以他基本上说得很对……因为亚历山大知道尼古拉只有阿米巴原虫般的脊梁。是的。所以他基本上，她非常热衷于让他和拉斯普京厮混在一起，因为她认为拉斯普京会某种程度上
you know we'll man him up exactly we'll man him up and rasputin is constantly saying you know be strong the people love the czar they hate the politicians all this kind of stuff um but i suppose rasputin also it's not just what he says, it's how he's, because he is charismatic, isn't he? He has these amazing eyes, doesn't he? I mean, that's the thing everybody goes on about, that they kind of burn and blaze and reach deep into you. And he has this persona.
你知道的，会让他振作起来，没错，会让他振作起来，而拉斯普京不断地说，你知道的，要坚强，人民爱沙皇，他们恨政客，所有这些类似的话，嗯，但我猜拉斯普京，这不仅仅是他说了什么，而是他的外表，因为他很有魅力，不是吗？他有双迷人的眼睛，不是吗？我的意思是，那是每个人都在谈论的事情，它们仿佛在燃烧、炽烈，深入你的内心。他有这样一种人格。
So he plays the part of the kind of holy man. He has the beard and he, the way he, his sort of peasant, everyone always says he has terrible table manners. He kind of rips apart the food with his hands and all this kind of stuff. But again, that kind of Byzantine idea that, you know, the emperor and the peasant and that in poverty and in kind of the dirt and soil of the peasant lands,
所以他扮演着圣人的角色。他留着胡子，他，他那种农民的做派，每个人都总是说他的餐桌礼仪很糟糕。他用手把食物撕碎，所有这些类似的东西。但话说回来，那种拜占庭式的理念，你知道的，皇帝和农民，在贫困中，在农民土地的泥土和土壤中，
their true Christianity is to be found. Their truth is to be found. And Rasputin is a kind of walking embodiment of that idea. But pretty much straight away, or quite early on, people around the court start saying he's no good. There's something dodgy about him. So you have rumors so there's this story there are these stories that he basically sits on the girls
可以找到真正的基督教。可以找到他们的真理。而拉斯普京就是这种理念的行走的化身。但几乎从一开始，或者很早的时候，宫廷周围的人就开始说他不好。他身上有些可疑的地方。所以你有谣言，所以有这个故事，有这些故事说他基本上坐在女孩们的
beds when they're going to bed and stuff he's very fond of kissing isn't he he's very fond of kissing i think he's um he's quite a person he's if you're a mr man he'd be mr tickle i mean he's he's quite handsy and i think um, maybe we should get into Rasputin. Should we have a break and then come back and talk about Rasputin and women, do you think? Do you think that's a good plan? That's an amazing cliffhanger. What a cliffhanger. So we'll be back.
床上当她们准备上床睡觉的时候之类的事情，他非常喜欢亲吻，不是吗？他非常喜欢亲吻，我想他，嗯，他是一个相当……如果你是个先生先生，他就会是挠痒痒先生，我的意思是，他有点动手动脚，我想，嗯，也许我们应该深入探讨一下拉斯普京。我们应该休息一下，然后再回来谈谈拉斯普京和女人的关系，你觉得呢？你觉得这是个好计划吗？这真是个惊天悬念。多大的悬念啊。所以我们会回来的。
Obviously, if you've just rushed to take up our exciting special offer, you won't be listening to adverts. But if you haven't, you will be. And we will hear you back after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest of the entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com regular listeners to um to the show should be familiar now with unheard unherd.com which is the online magazine that's very kindly sponsoring the podcast um and for whom
显然，如果你刚刚冲去接受我们激动人心的特别优惠，你可能不会听广告。但如果你没有，你就会听到。我们会在休息后听你回来。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐真相》（The Rest Is Entertainment），这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、八卦猛料的地方，在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外单集以及提前购买现场门票的权限，请前往therestisentertainment.com，即 therestisentertainment.com。本节目的忠实听众现在应该对 Unherd (unherd.com) 很熟悉了，这是一家非常友好地赞助了本播客的网络杂志，并且为此
both of us dominic have written have we not we have indeed they're offering special deal to rest his history listeners three months free subscription which can be cancelled at any time normally one pound a week uh go to unheard.com forward slash rest to claim it um and this week they've suggested a couple of articles that listeners might be interested in, prompted by the theme of Rasputin. Yeah, modern Rasputin. The modern Rasputin that they've cited is Dominic Cummings. Yes. So they've written about him quite a lot on Unheard, they say. So they've got an article, I remember this article actually, by Ares Roussinos. And he basically said that whatever
我们两人，多米尼克，都写过文章，不是吗？我们确实写过。他们为《The Rest Is History》的听众提供了一项特别优惠：三个月的免费订阅，可以随时取消，通常是一周一英镑，访问unherd.com/rest即可领取，本周他们推荐了几篇文章，听众可能会感兴趣，这些文章是由拉斯普京的主题引发的。是的，现代拉斯普京。他们引用的现代拉斯普京是多米尼克·卡明斯。是的。所以他们在 Unherd 上写了很多关于他的文章，他们说。所以他们有一篇文章，我实际上还记得这篇文章，是阿里斯·鲁西诺斯写的。他基本上说，无论
Dominic Cummings' shortcomings, his analysis of the deficiencies of the state was dead right. Cummings has insisted that the British civil service is essentially unreformable, and perhaps within the framework of the inherited structures of the British state, says Mr Roussinos, he is right. But Tom, not everybody agrees with that, do they? No. So Freddie Sayers, not persuaded at all. Oh, my word. Trying to exercise the persuasive element from government, centralising power in order to bully through the bureaucracy
多米尼克·卡明斯的缺点是什么，他对国家缺陷的分析是绝对正确的。卡明斯坚信英国公务员制度基本上是不可改革的，也许在英国国家继承结构的框架内，鲁西诺斯先生说，他是对的。但是汤姆，并非所有人都同意这一点，对吧？是的。所以弗雷迪·赛尔斯，一点也不被说服。噢，天哪。试图从政府中剔除说服元素，集中权力以便霸凌官僚机构
and trying to run the country like a science project isn't such a great alternative. Is Dominic Cummings Rasputin? I mean, Rasputin never tried to run Russia like a science project. No. But, you know, the idea of the overmighty advisor. Yeah. You know, it's all good stuff.
并试图把这个国家当作科学项目来运营并不是一个太好的替代方案。多米尼克·卡明斯是拉斯普京吗？我的意思是，拉斯普京从没有试图把俄罗斯当作科学项目来运营。不。但是，你知道，过度强大的顾问的概念。是的。你知道，这都是好东西。
But no one accused Dominic Cummings of, what would the analogy be, sleeping with the late Prince Philip. I mean... Dominic! That's an absolutely shocking idea that I will now struggle to get out of my mind well decide for yourself go to unheard.com slash rest and now back to the show welcome back to the rest is history maybe you've just been listening to Tom Holland selling you mental health treatments,
但没有人指责多米尼克·卡明斯，类比会是什么，与已故的菲利普亲王睡觉。我的意思是……多米尼克！这是一个绝对令人震惊的想法，我接下来将很难把它从脑海中抹去，好吧，自己决定吧，前往unherd.com/rest，现在回到节目中，欢迎回到《The Rest Is History》，也许你刚刚在听汤姆·霍兰向你推销心理健康疗法，
or maybe you've been to restishistorypod.com to sign up for our special ad-free service. Either way, great delights await as we talk about Rasputin's record with the ladies. Tom, you have a question? Well, I mean, yeah, so this is the big question, and lots and lots of people ask this. We've got one here from Barry Grogan, a friend of the show. Was he really the lover of the Russian queen and Russia's greatest love machine? Well, he wasn't Russia's greatest love machine. We've already dealt with that.
或者你可能去过 restishistorypod.com 注册我们专属的无广告服务。无论哪种方式，当我们谈论拉斯普京与女士们的记录时，极大的乐趣正在等待着。汤姆，你有一个问题？好吧，我的意思是，是的，所以这是个大问题，很多人都在问这个。我们这里有一个来自节目之友巴里·格罗根的问题。他真的是俄罗斯女王的情人兼俄罗斯最伟大的爱情机器吗？好吧，他不是俄罗斯最伟大的爱情机器。我们已经讨论过这个了。
But was he a lover of the Russian queen? I would say no, definitely not. It would be completely and utterly alien to Alexandra's persona. It would run completely counter to everything we think about her, we know about her. And the very allegation, actually, the weird thing about that Boney M song is what that Boney M song does is it reproduces perfectly these very scatological, kind almost pre sort of french revolution marie antoinette style
但他是俄国女王的情人吗？我会说不，绝对不是。这与亚历山大的性格完全格格不入。它与我们对她的一切看法、对她的了解完全背道而驰。事实上，那个针对Boney M乐队歌曲的奇怪指控，最诡异的地方在于，那首歌完美地重现了那些非常粗俗的、几乎带有法国大革命前玛丽·安托瓦内特风格的
kind of pamphlets and cartoons that circulated in the 1910s about rasputin and alexandra that actually if you saw now you would be horrified by their misogyny and their kind of anti-semitism and all these kinds of things um and that whole all of that allegation that she was his lover never ever went away i mean there was nothing they could do to dispel it but it seems to be completely untrue i mean the echoes of marianne trinette are are really fascinating in fact i mean prince yusupov um the guy who ends up killing murdering um rasputin he had um marianne trinette's furniture in his palace it is weird accusations against Marie Antoinette was that that she was sexually insatiable and that she was a lesbian and so
那种在1910年代流传的关于拉斯普京和亚历山大的小册子和漫画。实际上，如果你现在看到它们，你会对它们的厌女情结、反犹太主义以及所有这些东西感到震惊，嗯，关于她是他的情人的所有这些指控，从来都没有消失过——我是说，他们根本无力消除这些传言——但这似乎完全是无稽之谈。玛丽·安托瓦内特的影子真的非常迷人，事实上，尤苏波夫亲王——也就是最终杀死、谋杀拉斯普京的那个人，他的宫殿里就有玛丽·安托瓦内特的家具。对玛丽·安托瓦内特的奇怪指控之一就是她对性永不满足，而且她是个女同性恋，所以
Alexandra she has this friend um Anna V. Rubova yeah Anna V. Rubova I think brilliant I don't know whether that's wonderfully said and And everyone said she had a... She was have... Massive fling with Alexandra. Yes. Which is not true. But actually, they were incredibly pious. And Anna was one of the people who introduced...
亚历山大有这么一个朋友，安娜·V·鲁博娃。对，安娜·V·鲁博娃，我觉得很棒。我不知道这算不算妙语连珠，反正人人都说她和亚历山大有着……有着不可告人的热烈恋情。是的。但事实并非如此，其实他们俩极其虔诚，而安娜正是那些介绍……
You know, she was a massive fan of Rasputin. They'd all sit together and pray. Yeah. And actually, Alexandra called Anna the cow, which was very... You wouldn't call somebody that if you were, you know, leaping into bed with them, would you? I mean, it's very unlikely.
你知道的，她是拉斯普京的超级粉丝。他们会坐在一起祈祷。是的。事实上，亚历山大管安娜叫“母牛”，这非常……如果你正和某人滚床单，你绝不会这样称呼对方，对吧？所以这非常不可能。
I wouldn't have thought so. But Dominic, I mean, again, so all this, part of the question is how and why do these stories come about? I guess it's essentially the kind of inherent prurience in a pre-revolutionary situation where there's a foreign queen who people don't particularly like that these stories kind of generate and if you've got someone like Rasputin then they they really start to swell and am I not right that there is one incident in particular
我也这么认为。但多米尼克，话说回来，所有这些传言，其中一部分问题在于这些故事是如何以及为何产生的？我猜这本质上是前革命时期一种特有的好色心理，当时有一个不受大众喜爱的外国王后，于是这些故事便油然而生。如果再加上拉斯普京这样的人，它们就会彻底甚嚣尘上。我没记错的话，其中有一起事件格外引人注目吧？
oh yes which takes place in 1915 at the Yar which is kind of a restaurant in yeah in Moscow tell us about that so this is one thing that a lot of people who'd known very little about Rasputin may vaguely have heard of. So the First World War has started. We'll come back to the First World War later in the episode. But the First World War has started. Rasputin has gone on a trip to Moscow. And he's gone out with some friends.
哦，是的，那发生在1915年的“雅尔（Yar）”，那是莫斯科的一家餐厅，讲讲那件事吧。所以，很多对拉斯普京知之甚少的人可能隐约听说过这件事。第一次世界大战已经爆发了（我们会在本集的后面再谈一谈第一次世界大战）。第一次世界大战已经爆发，拉斯普京去了一趟莫斯科，和一些朋友一起出去了。
And they've gone to this sort of nightclub restaurant. There's gypsy dancers there. And he dances with them. He's a great dancer. He loves dancing. He loves dancing. loves dancing um but but why wouldn't he he's from a peasant village where folk dancing and stuff will be absolutely part of the sort of standard weekly entertainment so it makes sense that he likes dancing so anyway he's
他们去了这种夜总会式的餐厅，那里有吉普赛舞者，他便和她们跳舞。他是个出色的舞者，他太喜欢跳舞了。他喜欢跳舞，喜欢跳舞，嗯……但话说回来，他为什么不跳呢？他来自一个农民村庄，民间舞蹈之类的活动绝对是标准的每周娱乐活动的一部分，所以他喜欢跳舞也合情合理。无论如何，他当时
there he's he supposedly interferes with the gypsy dancers kind of cuddling them and groping them and stuff then he gets drunker and drunker we know that Rasputin did like a drink he gets drunker and drunker at the Yahr uh eventually starts shouting about how much you know the the empress loves him and all this sort of stuff and then basically he takes out his penis and starts waving it around and says this is the altar at which the empress worships through this I rule Russia all this kind of thing and stories about this incident spread pretty quickly and have become part of they become absolutely a key part of rasputin's legend and their love machine kind of reputation are they true well they're not true
就在那儿。据说他调戏吉普赛舞者，搂搂抱抱、动手动脚的。然后他喝得越来越醉——我们知道拉斯普京确实好杯中物——他在“雅尔”餐厅喝得酩酊大醉。最后，他开始大喊大叫，说什么皇后有多么爱他之类的话。接着，基本上，他掏出了自己的阴茎，开始挥舞着说：“这就是皇后顶礼膜拜的祭坛，通过它我统治了俄国”，诸如此类的话。关于这起事件的故事传播得相当快，并最终成为了拉斯普京传奇中绝对核心的一部分，以及他那种“爱情机器”名声的来源。它们是真的吗？嗯，它们不是真的，
because this guy douglas smith who wrote this fantastic biography went back and looked at all the police files and he found in the police files that Rasputin that there was nothing about this incident that this absolutely hadn't happened that basically what happened was that the deputy interior minister who is a man called Junkowski that Junkowski had basically put the local um constabulary up to subsequently concocting a report that was fake because he hated Rasputin and he wanted to bring her down and that's absolutely the story of Rasputin in Petersburg is that he's getting it from everybody from his religious rivals so there's a monk called
因为写了这本精彩传记的家伙道格拉斯·史密斯（Douglas Smith）回去查阅了所有的警察档案。他在警察档案中发现，关于这起事件根本没有任何记录，这绝对是没有发生过的事。基本上，真实情况是副内政大臣（一个叫扬科夫斯基的人）指使当地的警察分局随后捏造了一份假报告，因为他讨厌拉斯普京，想把拉氏搞垮。这绝对是拉斯普京在彼得堡的真实写照：他遭到了来自各方面的打击，比如他的宗教竞争对手，有一个叫
Iliadur who's kind of conspiring against him the whole time he's a terrible man yes who gets defrocked and imprisoned in a monastery, and then he escapes dressed as a woman. He does, and he ends up in America, doesn't he? Yes. He ends up in L.A. or something eventually. I think he ends up as a kind of doorman. Well, he dies as a doorman. But before then, he's associated with Hollywood. Yeah, brilliant.
伊利亚多尔（Iliador）的僧侣一直在密谋反对他。他是个可怕的人，是的。他后来被剥夺神职并关进修道院，然后他女扮男装逃跑了。他确实这么做了，最后去了美国，不是吗？是的。他最后好像去了洛杉矶之类的地方。我想他最后成了某种看门人。好吧，他死的时候是个看门人。但在那之前，他与好莱坞有着千丝万缕的联系。是的，太精彩了。
So there's him, there's other bishops, but there's also lots of people within the kind of bureaucratic machine who resent rasputin's influence and the weird thing with rasputin is that basically everybody projects onto him everything they don't like about the political situation so people on the left people on the right you know people who are just sort of monarchists well and internationally as well isn't there because because there's um uh there's a's a British diplomat who says that he was at the ER and saw it. Yeah.
所以除了他，还有其他主教，官僚机构内部也有许多人痛恨拉斯普京的影响力。而拉斯普京最诡异的地方在于，基本上每个人都会把他们对政治现状的所有不满投射到他身上：左翼人士、右翼人士，还有那些仅仅是保王派的人……哦，在国际上也是如此，对吧？因为有个英国外交官声称他当时在“雅尔”餐厅亲眼目睹了这一幕。是的。
And then it turns out actually he was in Kiev all along. Yeah. Is that Robert Bruce Lockhart? He says, yeah, I definitely saw it. Saw remnants of it. The more kind of prominent that Rasputin becomes, the more he becomes a focus of international as well as internal Russian conspiracy theories. Because it becomes a kind of shorthand, I think, doesn't it, for the kind of bonkersness of pre-revolutionary Russia. Yeah, I think so. That you can reduce it all to the relationship
结果证明他当时其实一直在基辅。是的。那是罗伯特·布鲁斯·洛克哈特（Robert Bruce Lockhart）吗？他说，是的，我绝对看见了。看到了当时的残余影响。拉斯普京变得越发显赫，他就越成为国际以及俄罗斯内部阴谋的焦点。因为我认为，这成了一种代名词，不是吗？用来形容革命前俄罗斯的那种疯狂状态。是的，我也这么觉得。你可以把这一切都归结为
of these three people, Nicholas, Alexandra and Rasputin. And the almost sad thing when you read the stories, their relationship is actually so innocent and almost kind of, it's almost quite childlike, isn't it? Yeah. They get together and they pray and they talk, you know,
这三个人的关系：尼古拉、亚历山大和拉斯普京。当你阅读这些故事时，最令人感到近乎悲哀的是，他们的关系实际上是如此纯真，甚至几乎带有一种……几乎相当孩子气，不是吗？是的。他们聚在一起祈祷，交谈，你知道的，
the kids look like Rasputin. Our friend. Our friend. I mean, Nicholas and Alexandra send each other these incredibly childish letters where they call each other kind of lovey and all this kind of stuff. And they say, oh, our our friend is coming i can't wait to see him tomorrow isn't it gonna be nice we can talk about god pray and and meanwhile out on the streets people are
孩子们看起来就像拉斯普京。我们的朋友。我们的朋友。我的意思是，尼古拉和亚历山大互相发送这些极其幼稚的信件，在信中他们把对方叫做“亲爱的”之类的话。他们说：“哦，我们的朋友要来了，我等不及明天见到他了，这不是很棒吗？我们可以谈论上帝、祈祷。”与此同时，在街上，人们却在
distributing these well i mean i i suppose it's fair to say that according to the police records he he did use prostitutes he he had a kind of earthy approach um well he has this kind of slight harem doesn't he he does have a bit of our and um he's compared by his miras to the biblical prophets who all had kind of harems and things well clearly what happens is that um he attracts a lot of kind of i think the word that douglas smith uses is emotionally fraught women. So these are kind of often aristocratic women whose husbands are basically, you know, not the most faithful and are away a lot of the time. And these women have too much time on their hands. They can almost, you know, the storm clouds of revolution are kind of gathering overhead.
散发这些……好吧，我的意思是，根据警察记录，公平地说，他的确嫖过娼，他有一种比较接地气的生活方式……好吧，他有点像拥有一个小后宫，不是吗？他确实有点像有个后宫，而且他的崇拜者把他比作《圣经》中的先知，他们也都有各种后宫之类的东西。嗯，很显然发生的事情是，他吸引了大量——我想道格拉斯·史密斯（Douglas Smith）用的词是——“情感脆弱的女性”。所以这些通常是贵族女性，她们的丈夫基本上（你知道的）并不是最忠诚的，而且经常不在家。这些女性有太多闲暇时间，几乎可以感觉到……革命的暴风雨正在头顶聚集。
They turn to Rasputin for spiritual sustenance but they also end up getting something more um and there's some there's a story about he goes on sort of like the equivalent of a kind of school trip back to his village or something doesn't he with a load of women and there's a lot of groping on the train and then jumping into and out of bunks and stuff like this i mean basically yeah i mean basically he's he's not very well behaved you know he drinks sometimes he but he's not he's not a satire you know he's not um he's not he and he's not i think a rapist this claims that he was a rapist but it seems kind of unlikely not enough store and there's stories like roping but he's so he's some way short of Harvey Weinstein.
她们向拉斯普京寻求精神上的滋养，但最终也得到了更多……嗯，还有一个故事说，他带着一大群女人回他的村庄，进行了一次类似于学校春游的旅行，火车上有很多摸索调情，还有跳进跳出铺位之类的事情。我的意思是，基本上，是的，我的意思是，基本上他表现得不是很好，你知道的，他有时会喝酒，但他不是色魔，你知道的，他不是……他不是，而且我认为他不是强奸犯。有人指控他是强奸犯，但这似乎不太可能。虽然没有足够的证据，而且有搂搂抱抱的故事，但他离哈维·韦恩斯坦（Harvey Weinstein）还差得很远。
I think. Is that fair to say? That's a commendation. Well, so let's look at the slightly more positive side. Yeah. So the key incident that absolutely nails Alexandra's devotion to him is in 1912. At Spala. At Spala.
我是这么认为的。这样说公允吗？这倒是一种夸奖。好吧，让我们看看稍微积极的一面。是的。那么，彻底坐实亚历山大对他的忠诚的关键事件发生在1912年。在斯帕拉。在斯帕拉。
So they're in a kind of a coach. They're bumping's a kind of hunting lodge isn't it yeah they're in Poland Alexei her son is bit jolted up and down and starts to bleed internally and yeah he's eight I think isn't he and they all think he's going to die and the doctors are kind of giving up on him. And Alexandra writes to Rasputin. And Rasputin is in his village in Siberia. And Rasputin writes back, God has heard your tears and heard your prayers. Do not grieve. The little one will not die.
所以他们坐在一辆马车里。颠簸着——那是一个狩猎小屋，对吧？是的，他们在波兰。她的儿子阿列克谢（Alexei）被颠簸得上下震动，开始内出血，是的，他当时八岁，我想是的。他们都以为他要死了，医生们也快要放弃他了。亚历山大写信给拉斯普京。当时拉斯普京在西伯利亚的老家。拉斯普京回信说：“上帝听到了你们的泪水，听到了你们的祈祷。不要悲伤。这孩子不会死的。”
Do not allow the doctors to bother him too much. And these words come true. Yeah, learn bold. Now, the interesting thing is why and as far as i can tell the latest thinking is that basically if rasputin's words have any effect at all they're just a complete placebo effect they calm alexandra she completely believes in rasputin so she really calm alexi as well who also well because if your mum is but if your mum if you're eight and you are bleeding internally to death and your mum is is is rushing around your bedside and the doctors are prodding you and yeah so it's that line don't allow the doctors to bother him yeah the doctors
“不要让医生过多地打扰他。”而这些话成真了。是的，字字珠玑。现在，有趣的问题是为什么？据我所知，最新的看法是，基本上，如果拉斯普京的话真的有什么作用的话，那也只是一种纯粹的安慰剂效应。它让亚历山大平静下来，她完全相信拉斯普京，所以她也彻底安抚了阿列克谢，因为——如果你的妈妈……如果你八岁，你正在内出血走向死亡，而你的妈妈在你的床头跑来跑去，医生们还在对你动手动脚，是的。所以就是那句台词：“不要让医生去打扰他。”是的，医生们
because the doctors are making it worse and uh and then if your mum gets a telegram and says oh my gosh it's going to be all right you know you will relax and the argument is that alexa's blood pressure falls a little bit and he stops bleeding and or maybe it was a miracle well maybe it was a miracle it happens clearly he has an effect on the royal and the imperial family which is this very emotionally sort of intense household clearly he does calm them down yeah they like being with him he tells them what they want to hear about how the Russian people love them. They talk about God and nature and stuff like that. It's like a massive Sunday school.
因为医生们正在把事情搞得更糟。然后，如果你妈妈收到一笔电报说：“哦天哪，一切都会好起来的”（你知道的），你就会放松下来。大家的争论点在于，阿列克谢的血压稍微下降了一点，血止住了。或者也许是个奇迹？好吧，也许是个奇迹。显然，他对皇室和帝国家庭产生了影响，这是一个情感非常激烈的家庭。显然他确实让他们平静下来了。是的，他们喜欢和他在一起，他告诉他们他们想听的话，关于俄罗斯人民如何爱戴他们。他们谈论上帝、自然之类的话题。这就像一个巨大的主日学校。
And that's what makes the story quite tragic in a way. I mean, he is badly behaved outside the palace. But I mean, badly behaved. Not terribly. Yeah, badly behaved is possibly too strong, isn't it? And the thing is, he's not a priest, is he? No. He's not a priest is he um no he's not a monk uh he's he's a man of god which is different it's it's not like he's breaking any vows no he's not exactly he's long he's got a long-suffering wife back in you know wherever
这也就是为什么这个故事在某种程度上相当悲剧。我的意思是，他在宫殿外表现得很糟糕。但我的意思是，表现得很糟糕？也没有那么糟糕。是的，“表现糟糕”可能用词太重了，对吧？问题是，他不是一个神父，对吧？不。他不是神父，对吧？嗯，不，他不是僧侣。他是上帝的仆人，这有所不同。这不像是他在破什么戒。不，他没有。确切地说，他在（无论哪个地方）
it is but krov square but i don't think you know you don't get the impression she's terribly bothered it's this kind of byzantine strain within russia where it's it's it's it's kind of less significant than it is say in a catholic or even protestant tradition um so i think yeah uh so there's that and then and then 1914 so that letter that that we opened yeah he sends that from his sickbed, though, doesn't he? So we've got a question from the Reasonable Doctor. Is there any good evidence that he did warn Tsar Nicholas that if Russia went to war against the Central Powers, then Sardin would collapse?
克罗夫广场（Krov Square）有一个饱经风霜的妻子，但我认为你不会觉得她有多烦恼。这是俄罗斯境内的一种拜占庭式的传统，它（相比于天主教甚至新教传统）显得没那么重要。所以我想，是的，就是这样。然后是1914年，我们开篇提到的那封信……是的，不过他是从病榻上发出那封信的，不是吗？所以我们有一个来自“理智医生”的问题：有什么好证据表明，他确实曾警告尼古拉沙皇，如果俄国对同盟国开战，沙皇政权就会崩溃？
I mean, kind of. Yeah, there absolutely is. That is kind of what he's saying. So he'd said that two years before in the Balkan Wars, by the way. He'd said, don't go to war two years earlier. So he's an anti-war figure. Yeah. Like a lot of the Russian peasantry, they don't like war generally.
我的意思是，某种程度上是的。绝对有。这确实就是他所说的。顺便说一句，他在两年前的巴尔干战争中就说过这样的话。他两年前就说过不要开战。所以他是一个反战人物。是的。就像许多俄罗斯农民一样，他们普遍不喜欢战争。
When Russia goes to war, the reaction of most of the Russian peasants is horror because they think, well, God, we'll just be slaughtered by our incompetent officers. And they will. They are. Yeah, and they are. And what's really interesting is that basically, what is it, nine days, I think, something like nine, you know, 11 days before the assassination of Franz Ferdinand, Rasputin has himself been the victim of an assassination attempt. So he has been stabbed in his home village by a woman called Kionya Guseva, who has no nose. Like the person who Nelson gave the snuffbox to.
当俄国参战时，大多数俄国农民的反应是惊恐，因为他们心想：“天哪，我们只会遭到我们那些无能军官的屠杀。”他们也确实如此。他们确实遭到了屠杀。是的。而真正有趣的是，基本上，在弗朗茨·斐迪南大公遇刺前大约九天（我想大概是九、十一天吧），拉斯普京本人也成为了一起暗杀未遂事件的受害者。他在自己的老家被一个名叫基奥尼亚·古谢娃（Kionya Guseva）的女人刺伤了，这个女人没有鼻子。就像纳尔逊把鼻烟盒送给的那个人一样。
Right, exactly. There's a definite theme here. But did you see the photo of her? She looked very unsettling, I thought. So she has no nose. Her nose has disappeared. I don't know whether it's some talk that it might be syphilis or something. She has no nose.
对，没错。这里有一个明确的主题。但你看到她的照片了吗？我觉得她看起来非常令人不安。所以她没有鼻子。她的鼻子不见了。我不知道这是否是因为梅毒之类的问题有这种说法。她没有鼻子。
She's as mad as a hatter. She has visions of the devil. But she's also been put up to it, it seems, by Rasputin's rival, Iliador, this monk who ends up fleeing to America. So Rasputin has been stabbed. He pulls through. And it's basically amid this. So he's away from Nicholas.
她疯得像个帽匠。她有关于魔鬼的幻觉。但她似乎也是受拉斯普京的死敌——伊利亚多尔（那个最后逃往美国的僧侣）的教唆才这么做的。所以拉斯普京被刺伤了。他挺过来了。基本上正是在这种背景下——所以他当时远离了尼古拉。
Now, there is a slight what if. If he'd been there in St. Petersburg, could he have stopped Nicholas from going to war? I don't think he could, actually. His influence, I think, is a bit overstated. Clearly, he is influential, but not that influential. When all the army commanders are basically saying, we have to go, we have to mobilize,
现在，这里有一个小小的假设：如果他当时在圣彼得堡，他能阻止尼古拉参战吗？我觉得他其实做不到。我认为他的影响力被夸大了。很显然他是有影响力的，但没那么大影响力。当所有的军队指挥官都基本上在说“我们必须参战，我们必须动员”，
we have to stand by Serbia. But Rasputin definitely says, disaster will, you know, don't do this. And Nicholas does. Yeah. So he goes to war. And then Nicholas makes the stupid, stupid mistake of saying, I will take supreme command of the army.
“我们必须支持塞尔维亚”时——但拉斯普京确实说过“灾难会……你知道的，不要这么做”。而尼古拉还是做了。是的。于是他参战了。然后尼古拉犯了一个极其愚蠢的错误，他说：“我将亲自担任军队的最高指挥官。”
So he previously had had his, what is it, his uncle or something, Grand Duke Nikolai, who's a man who wants, did you see this at a dinner party? Grand Duke Nikolai once was asked how good his sword was and he said i'll show you he drew his sword and um sliced a bull's eye dog down the middle have you you haven't seen the great have you no that's exactly the kind of that's exactly the kind of thing that happens in that but he sliced his own dog i mean his own it says like his own beloved pet well dominic if you watch the
在此之前，他的统帅是他的一位叔叔还是什么人，尼古拉大公（Grand Duke Nikolai）。这是一个什么样的人呢？你曾在晚宴上见过这种人吗？有人曾问尼古拉大公他的剑有多锋利，他说：“我给你们看看。”然后他拔出剑，把一只靶子狗从中间劈成了两半。你看过《凯瑟琳大帝》（The Great）这部剧吗？你没看过吧？不。那正是那种……那正是那种会在剧中发生的事情。但他劈的是他自己的狗！我的意思是，他自己的……据说就像他自己的爱犬一样。好吧，多米尼克，如果你看了《凯瑟琳大帝》，你绝对不会感到惊讶，对吧？事情就是这样发生的。总之，这个人在指挥俄国军队方面证明自己并不称职，尼古拉把他踢开，并宣布“我自己来指挥”。这对君主制来说绝对是一场灾难，因为这意味着一切现在都将归咎于他本人，没有人可以让他来背锅了。
great you will not be surprised right that happened well anyway this man didn't prove a very good commander of russia's arms nicholas boots him out and says i'll take command of myself which is an absolute catastrophe for the monarchy because it means that everything will now be laid at his door there's no one for him to fire and andrasputin and alexandra both know this and so that kind of further cements their relationship because they're back in petersburg yes kind of fretting about this yeah and nicholas is aware what's called stavka which is in modern day belarus in place called mogilev so stavka is the army headquarters so he's stuck there hundreds of miles away and that means that all the attention
拉斯普京和亚历山成都意识到了这一点，所以这进一步巩固了他们的关系，因为他们回到了彼得堡，是的，对此忧心忡忡。是的。尼古拉则清楚地知道所谓的“大本营”（Stavka）在哪里（位于现代白俄罗斯一个叫莫吉廖夫的地方）。大本营是军队总部，所以他被困在那里，距离几百英里之外。这意味着彼得堡的所有注意力
back in petersburg is now on alexandra and rasputin and everybody says they are running the country they are selling us to the germans and you get this absolute kind of upsurge in 1915 1916 of incredibly pornographic aggressive um sort of attacks on rasputin alexandra they're russian spies they're in league with the Jews, all of this kind of stuff actually, which gives you a sense I think, reading about Rasputin you do get a much stronger sense of the climate of the Russian Revolution and the violence of the 1920s and so on
现在都集中在亚历山大和拉斯普京身上。每个人都在说：“他们在统治国家，他们在把我们卖给德国人。”在1915年到1916年间，你看到了这种绝对激增的、极其色情的、具有攻击性的、针对拉斯普京和亚历山大的抨击。他们是俄国间谍，他们与犹太人勾结，诸如此类。这实际上让你对……我认为，通过阅读关于拉斯普京的书籍，你对俄国革命的气候以及20世纪20年代等时期的暴力有了更强烈的感受，
because you see just how poisonous that atmosphere was in the mid-1910s I know, imagine if they'd had social media things could have got really bad but the weird thing also is Rasputin is quite smart so Rasputin says the whole time there's not enough food for the cities
因为你看到了1910年代中期那种气氛是多么的有毒。我知道，想象一下如果他们当时有社交媒体，事情可能会变得多么糟糕。但诡异的是，拉斯普京其实挺精明的。所以拉斯普京一直都在说：“城市的粮食不够了，”
you need to get more food did you see these absolutely shambolic letters that he sends to the Minister of Agriculture Tom? no I miss them so Rasputin is barely literate so he sends these notes to the Minister of Agriculture. This is, I think, 1916 or 1915, 1916.
“你们需要获取更多粮食。”你看到他写给农业大臣汤姆的那些极其混乱的信件了吗？没有，我错过了。所以拉斯普京几乎是个文盲，他给农业大臣写了这些便条。这是在1916年或者1915、1916年左右吧。
Kind, dear apologies, forgive me, much meat is needed. Let Peter eat. Listen, help, Rasputin. Kind, dear apologies for the strange trouble, dear. Let them eat, not starve. They asked to eat, Rasputin. I mean, if you got that and you were the secretary of state for agriculture you'd be motivated to change policy wouldn't you well i suppose yes or
“亲爱的，抱歉，原谅我，需要很多肉。让彼得吃吧。听着，帮忙，拉斯普京。”“亲爱的，为这奇怪的麻烦道歉，亲爱的。让他们吃，不要挨饿。他们要求吃，拉斯普京。”我的意思是，如果你收到这个，而你是农业国务卿，你会被激起去改变政策，对吧？嗯，我想是的，或者
or perhaps think we've got to get rid of this guy and um murder him which yeah is in the end of 1916 what happens that's what happens isn't it and we get our second cross-dresser. Oh God, Prince Yusupov. Prince Yusupov. Now he's an awful man. Isn't he a terrible, terrible man? Claimed to be descended from the pharaohs and the nephew of the Prophet Muhammad, apparently. Yes.
也许会想：“我们得摆脱这家伙，然后谋杀他。”这就是1916年底发生的事情，不是吗？事情就是这样发展的。我们迎来了第二个易装癖者。哦天哪，尤苏波夫亲王。尤苏波夫亲王。他可真是个讨厌的人。他难道不是个极其糟糕、极其糟糕的人吗？据说他自称是法老和先知穆罕默德侄子的后代。是的。
And also, and I'm sorry to say, an Oxford man. A member of the Bullingdon Club. And a member of the Bullingdon Club. So I think it was Stephen Clarke, friend of the show, said, is he the only member of the Bullingdon Club and a member of the Bullingdon Club so I think it was Stephen Clarke friend of the show said is he the only member of the
而且，很遗憾地说，他还是个牛津人。牛津大学布灵顿俱乐部（Bullingdon Club）的成员。布灵顿俱乐部成员。我想史蒂芬·克拉克（Stephen Clarke），我们节目的老朋友，曾说过……他是不是布灵顿俱乐部成员中唯一一个……等一下，史蒂芬·克拉克说他是布灵顿俱乐部里唯一一个
Bullingdon Club to have murdered somebody I don't know I'm sure the Bullingdon Club have murdered more people than
谋杀过别人的人？我不知道。我敢肯定布灵顿俱乐部谋杀的人远不止
just Rasputin well according to the play about them I saw they did yeah really but that may not
拉斯普京一个。好吧，根据我看过的关于他们的戏剧，他们的确……是的，真的。但这可能
be strictly accurate so Felix is a he's an that's right i remember that so felix is an absolute spoiled brat isn't he's the second son his dad bought his mom a mountain for her birthday yeah he is this sort of he is a man that once you makes you want to be a leninist because he is the sort of embodiment of kind of greedy, grasping, entitled
并不完全准确。所以菲利克斯是一个……他是一个……没错，我想起来了。所以菲利克斯是一个绝对被宠坏的小屁孩，对吧？他是二儿子，他爹曾买下一座山送给他妈当生日礼物。是的，他就是那种……他是一个能让你恨不得想当个列宁主义者的人，因为他就是那种贪婪、攫取、享有特权的
Russian, yeah, elitist privilege. And he decides that he's going to kill Rasputin with a couple of other guys. There's a guy called Grand Duke Dmitry Pavlovich and a man who's sometimes been described as the first fascist, who's called Vladimir Pulishkevich, who's like an ultra-nationalist, anti-Semite, all of these. And bizarrely, they think that by killing Rasputin, they will shore up the monarchy, because they think it's only Rasputin who is damaging the monarchy.
俄国精英阶层特权的化身。他决定和另外几个人一起杀了拉斯普京。其中有一个人叫德米特里·巴甫洛维奇大公（Grand Duke Dmitry Pavlovich），还有一个有时被描述为“第一位法西斯分子”的人，名叫弗拉基米尔·普利什凯维奇（Vladimir Purishkevich），他是个极端民族主义者、反犹太主义者，诸如此类。而诡异的是，他们认为通过杀死拉斯普京，他们可以巩固君主制，因为他们觉得只有拉斯普京在损害君主制。
So they come up with this scheme, don't they? They get cyanide, they get pistols, and they set a date, the 16th of December, 1916. And do you want to tell the story, Tom? Because it is a good story. Yes. So Yusupov comes in person to pick Rasputin up from his house. And it's kind of midnight, isn't it?
于是他们想出了这个计划，对吧？他们弄到了氰化物、手枪，并定下了日子：1916年12月16日。汤姆，你想讲讲这个故事吗？因为这是一个极好的故事。好的。所以尤苏波夫亲自去拉斯普京的家接他。当时大约是午夜，对吧？
It is, yeah. Everyone thinks it's a bit weird to be... Yeah. And they drive back and Rasputin walks in and Yankee Doodle Dandy, what is it? Yankee Doodle Dandy is playing on the... They've basically set up this room, haven't they? This basement or something. Yeah, with cakes.
是的，没错。每个人都觉得这么做有点诡异……是的。然后他们开车回去，拉斯普京走了进去，背景音乐是《扬基歌》（Yankee Doodle Dandy），播放的是什么？他们基本上布置好了这个房间，不是吗？地下室之类的地方。是的，摆满了蛋糕。
They specially furnished it in a certain way. Absolutely laced with cyanide and all kinds of stuff. And also Madeira, poisoned Madeira. So this is, it has to be emphasised, this is the story that is told later by Yusupov. We'll come back to that. But according to him, Rasputin sits down, gobbles down a whole plate of cyanide-laced cakes. Shed loads of cakes.
他们以某种特定的方式专门布置了它。绝对下满了氰化物和各种各样的东西。还有马德拉酒，有毒的马德拉酒。所以这里必须强调的是，这是后来由尤苏波夫讲述的故事。我们等会儿会回到这一点。但据他所说，拉斯普京坐下来，狼吞虎咽地吃了一整盘掺了氰化物的蛋糕。一大堆蛋糕。
Unbelievable. Shed loads of cakes, massive cakes, huge. Yeah. Then he knocks back an entire bottle of poison Madeira. It has no effect on him. None. None whatsoever. So then they shoot him.
难以置信。一大堆蛋糕，巨大的蛋糕，超大号的。是的。然后他一口气干了一整瓶有毒的马德拉酒。这对他毫无影响。一点都没有。完全没有。所以他们只好开枪打他。
Well, doesn't Yusupov say, have a look at this crucifix? You'd want to look at it because I'm about to shoot you. Then he basically shoots him. Three times. I think, does he shoot him three times at first or does he shoot him? Then he says to his comrades and he says i've killed rasputin let's go and construct our alibi and stuff so they drive back and bury his body but they drive back to rasputin's house first of all and one of them
嗯，尤苏波夫不是说过吗：“看看这个十字架吧。”你肯定会想看一眼，因为我马上要开枪打你了。然后他基本上就开枪了。三枪。我想，他一开始是开枪三次，还是说他开了枪？然后他对他的同伙说：“我杀了拉斯普京，我们走吧，去伪造我们的不在场证明。”于是他们开车把尸体埋了。但他们首先开车去了拉斯普京的家，其中一个人
walks around in rasputin's hands be him to fool people then they go back to the the moika palace which is the place where they've killed him, and to get the body. And Rasputin... It's like Fatal Attraction. It is. Rasputin is bending down. Rasputin's eyes open and he kind of leaps up. Yusupov says...
戴着拉斯普京的手套到处走，为了愚弄别人。然后他们回到莫伊卡宫（Moika Palace）——也就是他们谋杀拉斯普京的地方——去取尸体。而拉斯普京……这简直就像电影《致命诱惑》（Fatal Attraction）。确实如此。拉斯普京弯着腰，突然眼睛睁开，整个人跳了起来。尤苏波夫说……
I have to read this because it is funny. Anyway, it's a terrible story. Yusupov says, A wild roar reckoned through the vaulted rooms. He rushed at me, trying to get at my throat and sank his fingers into my shoulder like steel claws.
我必须读一下这段，因为太搞笑了。总之，这是一个可怕的故事。尤苏波夫说：“一声野兽般的吼叫回荡在拱形房间里。他向我冲过来，企图掐住我的喉咙，把手指像钢铁爪子一样深深插进我的肩膀里。”
I realise now who Rasputin really was. It was the reincarnation of Satan himself who held me in his clutches and would never let me go until my dying day. So that really happened. And what is interesting is that he is writing this against the backdrop of the kind of the first horror films so nosferatu and everything and you it's not too hard to see where he's getting the idea for all this kind of
“我此刻才意识到拉斯普京真正的身份。他简直就是撒旦本尊的转世，他将我紧紧抓在魔爪之中，直到我生命垂尽也绝不放手。”所以这真的发生了。有趣的是，他是以第一批恐怖电影——比如《诺斯费拉图》（Nosferatu）等——为背景来写这些的。你并不难看出他这些
imagery yusupov probably himself isn't even writing it's a ghost writer right yeah yeah and also is it not the case that this is some scholars have said this is clearly actually a rip-off of a dostoevsky short story called the landlady yeah so yusupov is almost certainly making all this stuff about rasputin coming back to life there's even claims in crime and punishment yeah with the old lady uh yes so raskolnikov the murderer of this old moneylender in Crime and Punishment, he lived, supposedly, you know, fictionally, about three blocks from where Rasputin is murdered. I mean, it's a kind of incredible synergy there. It absolutely hangs over it all, doesn't it? And they take his body, don't they, suppose, and they dump it in the ice.
意象的灵感是从哪里来的。尤苏波夫本人可能根本没动笔，是个代笔人写的，对吧？是的，是的。而且，难道不是吗？一些学者指出，这显然是抄袭了陀思妥耶夫斯基一篇名为《房东太太》（The Landlady）的短篇小说。所以尤苏波夫几乎可以肯定是在瞎编那些关于拉斯普京死而复生的事情。《罪与罚》里也有类似的桥段，对吧？那个老太婆……是的，所以《罪与罚》中谋杀这个老高利贷者的凶手拉斯柯尔尼科夫（Raskolnikov），在小说虚构的设定中，据说他就住在拉斯普京被谋杀地点大约三个街区远的地方。我的意思是，这里面有一种不可思议的巧合。它绝对笼罩了整件事情，不是吗？他们把拉斯普京的尸体运走，扔进了冰层里。
And one of the kind of, one of the favorite stories, even then he's supposed to have scratched at the ice yeah utter balderdash apparently so i mean basically what even the poison cakes supposedly aren't true because his baris britain's daughter said he hated leaks yeah yeah he didn't he didn't like had our sweet tooth at all he'd never have eaten or played and so the context for this the context for this is that um yuspov has fled russia after the revolution he doesn't have any money yeah so he needs to he needs to make it as sensational as possible but they definitely we do know because there was an autopsy the record of the autopsy is lost but we do have interviews by the doctor who did the autopsy a year or so later and he said basically when they pulled Rasputin's body out of the river because the police find a boot and a sort of trail of
关于他最喜欢的传说之一，甚至在当时，人们都说他还在冰层上抓挠……这完全是胡说八道。显然，甚至连那些毒蛋糕的说法也并非事实，因为拉斯普京的女儿说他讨厌洋葱……呃，不对，他不喜欢甜食，他根本不会吃整盘蛋糕。所以这里的背景是，尤苏波夫在革命后逃离了俄国，他身无分文，所以他需要把故事编得尽可能耸人听闻。但我们确实知道（因为有尸检报告——尸检记录虽然丢失了，但我们有大约一年后进行尸检的医生的采访记录），他说基本上当他们把拉斯普京的尸体从河里拉出来时——因为警察发现了一只靴子和一路血迹——他们把拉斯普京的尸体拉上来，发现他身中三枪，
blood they pull Rasputin's body out he has been shot three times um and and that's it so clearly these guys just basically shot it and Nicholas and Alexandra are devastated, absolutely devastated. And obviously it doesn't rescue the monarchy, as the assassins hoped, because, I mean, they've only got weeks left before the monarchy is going to fall and the bread riots and St. Petersburg and army mutinies and so on. And they're kind of doomed themselves, aren't they? And there's tragic detail about when they are... So they're killed, obviously, more than a year later by the Bolsheviks. They basically are taken to Siberia.
仅此而已。所以很显然，这几个家伙基本上就是开枪打死了他。尼古拉和亚历山大悲痛欲绝，彻底心碎。显然，这并没有像刺客们所希望的那样拯救君主制，因为距离君主制倒台、圣彼得堡爆发面包暴动以及军队哗变等事件，他们只剩下几周的时间了。他们自己也难逃厄运，不是吗？关于他们遇害时，有一个悲惨的细节……当然，一年多后，他们被布尔什维克杀害了。他们被带到了西伯利亚。
So they make the reverse journey, the Romanovs, to the one that Rasputin has made. So Nicholas, Alexandra, the four girls, and Alexei. And when they're taken down to a basement, as Rasputin was, to be shot by the Bolsheviks, the girls all have amulets around their necks with Rasputin's picture and a prayer, I think, that he had written.
所以罗曼诺夫家族踏上了与拉斯普京相反的回归之旅。尼古拉、亚历山大、四个女孩和阿列克谢。当他们被带到地下室（就像当年的拉斯普京一样）准备被布尔什维克枪决时，女孩们的脖子上都挂着护身符，里面有拉斯普京的照片和一份他写下的祈祷文。
Topaz stones, isn't it? Yeah. That's kind of sewn in. But as they go down, they go past pornographic graffiti showing Alexandra and Rasputin having sex with Nicholas kind of sitting impotently on the side side so that's the last things that they see it's it's it's that is so sad actually i think it is a sad story there is something it is there is something slightly
托帕石的宝石，对吧？是的。那是缝在衣服里的。但当他们走下去时，他们走过了带有色情涂鸦的墙壁，上面画着亚历山大和拉斯普京在做爱，而尼古拉则在一旁无能为力地坐着。所以这是他们看到的最后一幕。这真的是……太令人心碎了。其实我认为这是一个悲剧故事。有一种……
readers digest about the uh the fate of the romanovs you know if you're a sort of um a middle-aged woman in 1950s tuscaloosa. This is the kind of thing you read about and gets you very worked up. But actually, I think it is a genuinely kind of moving story. I mean, they're completely out of their depth. You know, they're not great people, Alexandra and Nicholas. They're kind of hapless. But being murdered in a basement
罗曼诺夫家族的命运有一种《读者文摘》（Readers Digest）式的狗血感，你知道的，如果你是1950年代塔斯卡卢萨（Tuscaloosa）的中年妇女，这就是你会读到并为你带来极大情绪触动的故事。但实际上，我认为这是一个真正感人的故事。我的意思是，他们完全无法胜任自己的角色。亚历山大和尼古拉并不是什么伟人，他们有点倒霉。但在地下室里被谋杀
is probably not the fate you'd have wanted for them, just like Rasputin being shot and thrown into the river. Yeah, so, so I mean what I have kind of reading about it and the the contrast between the the incredible stories and what seems to be the truth I mean it kind of it's quite sobering you know when I think about all the stories told about various Roman emperors I was about to say, yeah. You really kind of... Because why... So I guess there's a question here. Karl Johan. Rasputin's penis is famously available to see in a sort of pickled state.
大概不是你希望他们迎来的结局，就像拉斯普京被枪杀并扔进河里一样。所以，我的意思是，当我阅读相关资料时，那些离奇传说与看似真相之间的对比，让我觉得相当清醒。每当我想到关于历代罗马皇帝的那些传说时……我正想这么说，是的。你真的会觉得……因为为什么……我猜这里有个问题：卡尔·约翰（Karl Johan）。拉斯普京的阴茎以其腌制状态而闻名，供人参观。
But where does the idea for that come from? Are there lots of pickled penises lying around in Russia? Patently European, is the pickled dick real? So I guess, you know, why? Obviously, it's not. No, because his body was, he wasn't castrated after his death, as some people claim,
但这东西的创意是从哪里来的？俄国有很多腌制好的阴茎到处都是吗？这显然很欧洲，那个腌制的小弟弟是真的吗？所以我想，你知道的，为什么？显然不是真的。不，因为他的尸体——他死后并没有像某些人所说的那样被阉割，
and his body was burned. So it's not him. So why are these stories? Why is all the stuff that you get in in uh bony m's single there i i it's the it's the kind of the swirl of factional and religious rivalries where people opposed to him have reasons to come up with these stories it's i i guess the the the relaxation of censorship after after 1905 that yes yeah newspapers can start writing this stuff um the revolution kind of you know there's there's absolute free reign to it there's royalists arguing that um
他的尸体被烧毁了。所以那根本不是他的。那为什么会有这些故事呢？为什么Boney M乐队的单曲里会有所有这些东西？我觉得，这是派系和宗教敌对势力相互纠缠的结果，反对他的人有动机编造这些故事。我猜，1905年之后审查制度的放松使得报纸开始撰写这些内容，革命的爆发也带来了绝对无拘无束的言论空间。保王派争辩说，
you know he he destroyed the monarchy without him it would all have been fine um and people on the left who see him as symptomatic of the decadence of the Romanov monarchy and the church. Yeah, absolutely. But also it's, it's also us. I mean,
是他摧毁了君主制，如果没有他，一切都会好好的；而左翼人士则视他为罗曼诺夫君主制和教会腐朽的象征。是的，绝对如此。但这也是我们自己的问题。我的意思是，
our natural prurience, right? I mean, the fact that we're doing Rasputin as a subject, the fact that so many people sent in questions, it reminds me a tiny bit of Mary. We asked Mary Beard about gladiators, you know,
我们对八卦的天然好感，对吧？我的意思是，我们把拉斯普京作为讨论的主题，那么多人发来问题，这让我想起了玛丽·比尔德（Mary Beard）关于角斗士的节目。我们问玛丽·比尔德关于角斗士的事：“罗马人喜欢角斗士，这不是很诡异吗？”而她非常合理地指出：我们也喜欢。我们虽然不喜欢去看真的角斗士决斗，但我们喜欢谈论他们。我们都喜欢去参观罗马斗罗场。我们既想吃蛋糕，又想把它留着。某种程度上，我认为我们对拉斯普京也是这样。对西方人来说，拉斯普京难道不也强化了
isn't it weird that the Romans like gladiators? And she pointed out quite reasonably. We like them too. We don't like to watch them, but we like to talk about them. We all like to go to see the Colosseum. We kind of have our cake and eat it. And in a sense, I think that's what we do with Rasputin. Rasputin also, for Westerners, doesn't he also reinforce
俄罗斯具有东方色彩的这种印象吗？哦，作为俄罗斯人。是的，那是歌里的最后一句词，不是吗？我的意思是，这基本上反映了一种观念：这就是俄罗斯会发生的事情。这是一个充满自我阉割和自虐者的异国情调的世界。不过，难道不是因为关于他生平的很多一手资料在苏联时期根本无法获取吗？但你知道有趣的是什么吗？苏联人非常讨厌Boney M乐队。
a sense of Russia as Eastern? Oh, as Russians. Yeah, that's the last line of the song, isn't it? I mean, that's basically this sense that this is what happens in Russia. It's an exotic world of people who castrate themselves and whip themselves. Isn't it also, though, that a lot of the source material for his life wasn't available during the Soviet Union? But you know the interesting thing? The Soviets were very down on Boney M.
所以当Boney M在俄罗斯发行音乐时，他们是不被允许收录那首歌的。这是为什么呢？因为基本上克里姆林宫不喜欢人们……
So Boney M, when they released music in Russia, were not allowed to include that song. Why was that? Because basically the Kremlin didn't like people, you know. Being rude about the Romanos. No, I think they thought it probably glamorised the Romanos and glamorised Rasputin and that this was basically. Oh, I see. This was an inappropriate way to think about this.
对罗曼诺夫家族口出恶言。不，我想他们可能认为这美化了罗曼诺夫家族，美化了拉斯普京，这基本上是……哦，我明白了。他们觉得以这种方式来看待这段历史是不合适的。
What they would have said was a terrible chapter in Russian history, I guess. Supposedly, even when Bonian played in Poland, the Polish authorities said, don't do Rasputin. You know, it's not our overlords are not very happy with it. But now there are people who do think he was a saint in russia who i mean just as there are people who who see nicholas and and alexandra as saints they see you know he's been uh he has been rehabilitated and i think there are there are kind of nationalist historians yes who say that rasputin has been framed who that um actually he never you, he never groped women,
他们会说这是俄国历史上糟糕的一章吧。据说，甚至当Boney M在波兰演出时，波兰当局也说：“别唱《拉斯普京》。”你知道的，我们的统治者对此不太高兴。但现在也有人认为他在俄国是个圣徒，就像有人把尼古拉和亚历山大视为圣徒一样。他们认为他已经被平反了。我认为有一些民族主义历史学家，是的，他们说拉斯普京是被陷害的，
all of these kinds of things. So they've almost gone to the opposite extreme. And they say he's just been smeared by kind of foreign propaganda and stuff. So it is an extraordinary story. And actually, you know, Tom, it does make me think about Suetonius and the Twelve Caesars and all those sources for Roman emperors that are wallowing in the same kind of pornographic material.
实际上他从未调戏过女性，诸如此类的事情。所以他们几乎走向了另一个极端。他们说他只是被外国宣传等手段抹黑了。所以这是一个非凡的故事。事实上，汤姆，这确实让我想起了苏埃托尼乌斯（Suetonius）的《十二帝王传》（The Twelve Caesars）以及所有那些沉溺于同类色情材料的罗马皇帝史料。
Because the, you know, Iliadore's kind of muckraking that he wrote in America and Yusupov's book, you can kind of imagine, you know, if those are the only sources that you have in 2000 years time, what would you make of Rasputin? I mean, it'd be very difficult to, I mean, it would be impossible to get beneath it. So yeah, really fascinating.
因为伊利亚多尔在美国写的那些抹黑文章，还有尤苏波夫的书……你可以想象一下，如果2000年后你手里只有这些资料，你对拉斯普京会有什么看法？我的意思是，那将很难……我的意思是，根本无法透过现象看本质。所以，这确实非常迷人。
So a fascinating story in itself and fascinating historiographically. And with that, I think rah, rah, Rasputin. Do we want to remind people, Tom, of our fascinating club, our really exciting club? Yeah, we do, we do. So it's breastishistorypod.com, live stream and
所以这是一个本身就很迷人的故事，从历史学角度来看也极其吸引人。伴随着这一切，我想说：啦，啦，拉斯普京。汤姆，我们要不要提醒大家我们那个迷人的俱乐部、那个令人兴奋的俱乐部？对，我们要的，我们要的。网址是britishistorypod.com，有直播和
the bonus episode and yeah this exciting discord chat room uh yeah you can we'll so we'll put a reading list on that we'll put um books on about recipes you particularly enjoyed um all that kind of stuff uh and you'll get bonus episodes so if you have further thoughts about this that you'd like us to talk about uh in next week's episode put them there let us know um put it on twitter whatever uh so uh lots to look forward to um and our next episode is i'm delighted to say on the subject of cricket to mark the start of the ashes so we'll see you on there on thursday goodbye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad-free listening There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
还有独家番外篇，对，还有这个令人兴奋的Discord聊天室，呃，对，你可以——我们会把书单发到上面，我们还会放一些关于你特别喜欢的食谱的书籍，诸如此类的事情。你会得到独家番外篇，如果你对这期节目还有什么想让我们在下周的节目中探讨的想法，尽管发到那里，让我们知道，发到推特上，随便哪里。所以，有很多值得期待的内容。我们的下一期节目，我很高兴地宣布，主题是板球，为了庆祝灰烬杯的开始，所以我们周四见。再见，感谢收听《历史的剩余》，想要获取独家番外篇、提前收听和无广告收听...... 本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。